- [Voiceover] In recent
years the amount of C O two
released by humans into
the planet has approached
40 billion, 40 billion tons and if
you wanted to break that
down based on people
well we've recently crossed seven billion
people on the planet so that's going to be
approximately seven billion
people, seven billion people
times the amount of tons per person
and so if you work out the math,
40 divided by seven is
going to be roughly 5.7
5.7 tons per person, tons per person.
And this might already seem like a lot,
you can imagine 5.7 tons
of wood just being burned,
actually it would have to be
more than 5.7 tons of wood
because wood contains some water.
But it's even more than that because,
or at least for many of you all watching,
it's going to be a lot more than that,
because that's the
average of the developed
and the developing world and it turns out
that the average person
in the developed world,
so developed, developed average,
or if you're a wealthy person or a
middle class person in
even the developing world,
your average is going
to be closer to 20 tons,
20 tons, per person, per year
and in the developing world, or if you're
not as wealthy of a
person or you're living
in a rural place and
you're not using your car
to get to where you need to get to
or your house doesn't have electricity,
so the poor, the poor, are using closer to
one ton of C O two per person, per year.
And so this already when
you even see this dynamic,
it leads to something interesting.
The number of people on the planet
is only likely to increase
and we can see that.
We have a little chart here from,
based on data from the UN,
I know the numbers here
are a little bit small, it starts in 1800
and it goes all the way to 2100
and the blue are the actuals, if you
want to see where we are right now,
so we are not quite at 2020 yet,
so we're gonna be
roughly right over there.
That's where we are right now,
we've recently crossed
seven billion people
and if you wanted to see where these
UN predictions have us for 2050,
2050 is right over here and so
you can see the high UN prediction has us
getting to a world population of about
ten and a half billion,
the medium prediction
has us crossing nine billion,
this is like a little bit,
maybe 9.3, 9.4 billion and
then the low prediction
still has a population increasing a bit,
it's crossing eight
billion people worlwide.
So this number is
clearly going to increase
and so you can also imagine
we want it to happen
that more people get out of poverty,
that they are able to use, to
have more goods and services
and so in that case well, they
might be using more energy.
And if we don't change how
we produce that energy,
well this has the potential
of really going up a lot,
which could make this number go up a lot.
And to help us think about
that a little bit more
Bill Gates gave his famous
TED talk a couple of years ago
where he talked about his energy equation,
and it's a pretty
straight forward equation,
it talks about the total
sum of C O two emissions.
So this is the capital Greek
letter sigma right over here,
it's shorthand math,
math shorthand for sum.
So the annual sum of C O two emissions,
and so that's that 40 billion number
that I was talking about before,
well you can derive this in any given year
by taking the product of several things.
First you can think about
the world's population, P,
I'll even call that the average population
because the population is changing,
so the average population in a year,
average population in a year and then
you can multiply that times the amount of
services on average each
person is using per year.
So times the services,
let me write that down,
the average services,
average, average services
per person, per person and really
we could say average services and goods.
Because we are talking
about things that are,
that are going to need energy
and any good or service pretty much,
that you look around is going to need
energy for you to consume.
There's some of the obvious things like
transportation, obviously
your car might consume
some fuel, it needs energy to do that.
But even watching this
video, I'm consuming energy
producing this video for you, I had to
eat some food, some energy
which is, the reason
I eat it is for energy
and some energy was used
even to produce that food,
to get it to my table,
I am using electricity
on my computer right now,
you would have to use electricity
to consume this video,
so there's a lot more energy being
used in the goods and services you
consume than you might realize.
So then you want to take, and remember
we want to get to the
total sum of C O two,
you multiply that times the average energy
per service, or you could say
per good or service consumed.
So average, I'll just
services, average energy,
average energy per service, per service.
I'll just write the word
per, so per, per service
right over there, as I
said almost any service
you use, you consume is using some energy.
When you go to school your teacher,
he or she is consuming
energy, to just be alive,
they had to eat some food, they had to
use transportation to
get there, your classroom
might be heated or it might
be cooled in some way.
And then finally to get
us to the sum of C O two
released in a year, we
have to multiply by,
we have to multiply by, let me do that in
the color I'm using for the C O two,
we have to multiply
that times the C O two,
C O two released, released per
unit of energy, per unit of energy.
And so, you can, we
can think about how all
of these dynamics are going to change
but if we ever want this thing
on the left to get to zero,
and unless it gets to zero, things like
global warming are only
going to get worse,
in order for that to get
to zero and you're taking
the product of four things, at least one
of these things have to be zero.
That's the only way that you're
going to get a product to be zero.
Now we could look at each of these,
each of these elements
of the energy equation
and think about what
they are likely to do.
The average world population, well we see
what's going on here,
even the medium prediction
has the population growing by roughly 30%
so we can say look, this
is going to increase,
this is going to increase
by, by a factor of 1.3,
it's going to increase by roughly 30%,
once again these are all
predictions, this is all very rough
but we can think directionally
where things are going.
Now, average goods and services,
or average services per
person, well we want the poor
to be able to consume
more, now maybe some of us
in the developed world, maybe we consume
a little bit too much, you know,
that's a philisophical
thing for folks to debate
but on average we want the world, we want
more people to have better transportation,
better access to healthcare, better access
to education, better access to leisure.
And so this is likely to go up,
in fact this will go up
as the world grows richer
and some of the predictions,
and this is what was,
I believe what Bill cited in his TED talk,
was that this could go
up by a factor of two,
this could go up by a factor of two,
and this is good, we want
the world to become richer,
we want more people to
consume goods and services.
Now, the average energy per service.
Well the good thing is technology is
making things more
efficient, and so we might
have better insulation,
better efficient engines,
whether they're electric engines or
some other type of fuel engines,
and so the average energy per service
is likely to go down, it depends on
how optimistic you are,
it could go down by
20% and depending on
your time frame, 50% and
some even more optimistic predictions
might be even more than 50%, so
it's gonna go down, so let's
just say this is times,
let's just use 0.5,
let's just be optimistic.
But even if you were to multiply this,
you know, just 1.3 times two, that's
a factor of 2.6 and even if you were
to take that by half you still have
this entire product increasing.
And even if we were to
get really efficient,
if we were to, if we were
to decrease our energy used
per service by 80% or even 90%
you still have many
tens of billions of tons
of C O two being released every year.
So the only way we're going
to be able to get that,
to get this thing down to zero,
is if, is if C, right over here,
the C O two released per unit of energy
goes to zero, it needs, so
this needs to go to zero.
Which is a fairly bold
thing to say because
we're nowhere close to that right now
but if we're serious about this,
it's possible that humanity can get there.
There are energy sources
that are, that don't
release C O two or get pretty
close to being at zero.
And just to be clear,
even if you're driving
an electric car, you have to think about
where does that electricity come from?
If that electricity
was generated using say
something like coal, well
that's going to release C O two
or if it was generated using natural gas,
that is going to release
carbon into the atmosphere.
And so you need to think about,
even if you are using something
like an electric motor, how is that
electricity actually produced?
And you have energy sources, like nuclear,
nuclear has it's own set of issues
that we think about, like safety
and what you do with the waste
but people are working on things
like clean burning nuclear
that are much safer
and generate a very small
fraction of the waste.
You have all your other
renewable souces of energy
but this is a big challenge for humanity.
If we want this thing
on the left to be zero,
if we wanna slow, or if we wanna
stop the heating of the planet
we have to figure out how to do this.
And the general sense
is, if as a civilization,
we put our minds to it that we can do it.